die K Frage der wüstwums moment mal wir
hatten doch gefühlt erst gestern
Bundestagswahl und seitdem erst einen
neuen Kanzler da wird schon wieder über
den nächsten diskutiert na ja
tatsächlich tauchen in den vergangenen
Wochen und Monaten immer neue
schlagzeahlen und Gerüchte um den
nächsten Kanzlerkandidaten der Union auf
es war mit unter ein Thema in den
Sommerinterviews gut es ist Halbzeit in
der aktuellen Legislaturperiode da kann
man schon mal einen Blick über den
regierungsrand werfen was da diskutiert
wird und was die umfrageerte des ZDF
Barometers dazu sagen das schauen wir
uns jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer
[Musik]
an seit rund 20 Monaten regieren SPD
Grüne und FDP in Berlin in unseren
letzten Videos der Reihe Politbarometer
to go haben wir immer wieder analysiert
wie es bei der Ampel und Kanzler Olaf
Scholz so läuft während nach der
Regierungsbildung 64% der Befragten des
ZDF politbarometers mit der Regierung
zufrieden waren überwiegt seit dem
Frühjahr 2023 sich die Unzufriedenheit
mit der Ampel am 15 September bewerrten
nur noch 39% der Befragten die Arbeit
der Bundesregierung mit gut 55% sind
eher unzufrieden und das schlägt sich
auch in der sogenannten Projektion
nieder also der Frage wen man wählen
würde wenn am kommenden Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre die SPD käme dann
nämlich n noch auf 17 % die Grünen auf
16 die FDP auf 6% das wären in Summe nur
noch 39% und die Ampel hätte keine
Mehrheit mehr stärkste Kraft wäre jetzt
die Union mit 26%. kleiner Spoiler zwar
sagt die Mehrheit der Befragten des ZDF
politbarometers die CDU CSU würde auch
nicht besser regieren aber nach
aktuellem Stand könnte der nächste
Bundeskanzler tatsächlich wieder aus den
Reihen der CDU oder CSU kommen und
tatsächlich dreht sich das
Kanzlerkandidaten Karussell der
konservativen jetzt schon kräftig im
Kreis stand jetzt sind da vor allem vier
Kandidaten im Spiel und ja es sind
tatsächlich nur Männer in der nach
Merkel eha auf dem Tableau wer der
nächste konservative Kanzler nach Merkel
werden soll ist vor allen Dingen auch
eine programmatische Entscheidung wo
sieht sich die Union aktuell im
politischen Spektrum und wer
repräsentiert das als künftiger
Kanzlerkandidat am besten nach der
verlorenen Bundestagswahl 2021 hat die
CDU ihr Grundsatzprogramm aktualisiert
und sich nach eigenen Aussagen auf ihre
Grundwerte besonnen chrislich sozial
konservativ bürgerlich eine Volkspartei
mit und das klingt neu dem Ziel eines
konsequenten Klimaschutzes aber in der
Opposition ist die Union im Bundestag
aktuell gerade gegen die Politik der
grün sehr laut gleichzeitig scheint die
vielzitierte Brandmauer gegen Rechts
hier und da zu bröcke schauen wir uns
die vier potenziellen Kandidaten und
ihrer Ambitionen mal ein bisschen
genauer an wer Kanzlerkandidat der Union
hört der denkt natürlich unweigerlich an
den starken Mann aus Bayern genau gesagt
aus Franken Markus Söder ist
Parteivorsitzender der CSU der
bayerischen Schwester der CDU seit 2018
ist er Ministerpräsident im Freistaat
Bayern bei der Landtagswahl Anfang
Oktober möchte er diesen Posten
verteidigen laut Politbarometer extra
vom 8 September würde Söders CSU zwar
ein etwas schlechteres Ergebnis erzielen
als 2018 trotzdem sind seiner Partei
nach wie vor die meisten Stimmen sowie
ihm eine Wiederwahl als
Ministerpräsident ziemlich sicher vor
zwei Jahren hätte sich Markus Söder gut
vorstellen können Bundeskanzler zu
werden oder Kandidat zumindest musste
sich aber nach einem heftigen Machtkampf
zwischen den Schwestern CDU und CSU
Armin Laschet aus nordrheinen Westfalen
geschlagen geben der wiederum hat die
Union dann erstmals nach 16 Jahren
kichernd in die Position geführt musste
das Kanzleramt Olaf Scholz von der SPD
überlassen ein solches debakkel soll
nächstes Mal vermieden werden sagt die
CDU und sagt auch die CSU Söder selbst
lehnt allerdings eine Kandidatur als
konservativer Kanzlerkandidat ab für
mich ist die Sache erledigt ich hatte
ein mein Angebot gemacht dann haben sich
eben Mehrheiten anders ergeben das habe
ich zu respektieren und meine
Lebensaufgabe ist Bayern und nicht nur
mein Platz sondern auch meine
Lebensaufgabe ich stehe da nicht zur
Verfügung Söder konzentriert sich vor
allem auf den bayerischen Wahlkampf und
liegt seine Wählerinnen und Wähler im
Freistaat in Sicherheit auch die
kommenden 5 Jahre in München bleiben zu
wollen für Berlin empfiehlt er einen
anderen Kandidaten vielle genügend
hervorragende ein an Friedrich Merz ist
aus meiner Sicht natürlich zunächst mal
der geborene Kandidat Friedrich märz ist
Parteivorsitzender der CDU im Januar
2022 hat er in einem CDU
Mitgliederentscheid rund 95% der Stimmen
für sich verbuchen können märz ist auf
diesem Posten der Nachfolger von Armin
Laschet der nach der verlorenen
Bundestagswahl nicht noch mal zur Wahl
des parteichfs angetreten war zudem ist
er Fraktionsvorsitzender der CDU CSU im
Bundestag und damit der
Oppositionsführer in dieser Rolle
polarisiert er besonders gern
insbesondere wenn es sich um Lehrerinnen
handelt dass sie ihre Söhne die kleinen
Paschas da mal etwas zurechtweisen
Friedrich märz fällt immer wieder mit
populistischen Tönen auf und äckt auch
in den eigenen Reihen an als er sich im
ZDF sommerinterview für einen
pragmatischen Umgang mit der AFD auf
kommunaler Ebene ausspricht z.B
Politiker der ampelparteien aber auch
eigene Parteifreunde werfen ihm vor die
von ihm selbst beschworene Brandmauer
gegen Rechts aufzuweichen oder sogar
einzureißen Friedrich märz ist schon
sechsfacher Oper nach der kommenden Wahl
wird er 69 Jahre alt sein gut für
US-amerikanische Präsidenten kein Alter
und auch CDU urkanzler Konrad Adenauer
hat mit weit über 80 noch regiert obwohl
März längst einen Rentenanspruch hat ein
man noch Kanzler werden für ihn eine
Frage der Verantwortung auch in meiner
Generation hat man die Pflicht natürlich
Vorbereitung zu treffen für nachfolgende
Generation aber auch selbst noch
Verantwortung zu übernehmen und genau
das mache ich ja Friedrich Merz sieht
seine Kanzlerkandidatur als Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender vermutlich als
gesetzt aber ausgerechnet in seiner
Heimat
Nordrhein-Westfalen könnte ihm ein
jüngerer Kollege ernsthafte Konkurrenz
machen nämlich Hendrik wüst auch er ist
ein Nachfolger von Armin laschett erst
seit der IH 2021 als Ministerpräsident
in nordren-westfalen beerbt wurde dann
2022 auch noch gewählt koaliert in
Düsseldorf mit den Grünen als
Vorsitzender der CDU in NRW führt er den
mitgliederstärksten Verband mit seinen
verhältnismäßig jungen 48 Jahren wird er
von der Presse schon mal als
konservativer posterby bezeichnet und er
weiß genau wie er sich entsprechend
inszeniert Mitte Juni druckt die FAZ
einen Gastbeitrag von wüst ab in diesem
Artikel betont er den Charakter der CDU
als Volkspartei beruft sich auf
christliche Werte und ruft das Erbe von
Helmut Kohl und Angela Merkel in
Erinnerung spalterischen Populismus
erteil eine Absage das kann durchaus als
Seitenhieb in Richtung der
bundesparteiführung also Friedrich Merz
verstanden werden im NRW Wahlkampf
präsentiert sich wüst im vergangenen
Jahr betont sportlich jung
zukunftsorientiert als moderner Vater
einer kleinen Tochter möchte meiner
Tochter eine Welt hinterlassen in der
Klimaschutz Wohlstand und soziale
Sicherheit miteinander versöhnt sind und
ers schiebt hinterher Ministerpräsident
zu sein ist für mich die größte Ehre
meines Lebens Ministerpräsident in
Düsseldorf ist das mklich nicht mehr
steigerbar wüst hat sich selbst ins
kanzlerkandidatenkarussell der
konservativen geschleust und zwar indem
er einfach mal fast nichts gesagt hat in
einem Zeitungsinterview antwortet er im
Juni ausweichend auf die Frage ob er
sich die Kanzlerkandidatur vorstellen
könnte betont lediglich seine Aufgaben
legen aktuell in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Beobachter
interpretieren das durchaus als Ambition
aus Kanzleramt und Friedrich märz als
Provokation der schießt bei Berlin
direkt im ZDF zurück wir haben eine
Entscheidung im Spätsommer 2024 zu
treffen und bis dahin befassen wir uns
nicht mit Personalspekulationen sondern
mit Themen die Unzufriedenheit auch in
den Ländern auch leider in
nordrin-westfalen aus dem ich ja komme
mit der Landesregierung ist fast genauso
groß wie die mit der Bundesregierung tja
und damit ist der Bundestagswahlkampf im
Grunde schon zwei Jahre vor der
eigentlichen Wahl eröffnet womöglich
steigen die Kandidaten auf dem Rummel
der Befindlichkeiten demnächst aus dem
Karussell in einen Autoscooter um indem
es ja bekanntlich gern zu Rempeleien
kommt Rückendeckung erhält Hendrik wüst
aus steswig Holstein Ministerpräsident
Daniel Günther hält wüst für einen der
wichtigsten Köpfe der Union gleichzeitig
gilt Günther selbst als potenzieller
Kandidat der 50-Jährige ist seit 2017
Ministerpräsident von schlesbich-
Holstein und gilt als eher unauffällig
ähnlich wie Hendrik wüst aber im
Gegensatz zu Söder und März sieht Daniel
Günther in den grünen keinen politischen
Gegner sondern einen
Koalitionspartner Günther möchte
enttäuschte ampelwähler für die CDU
gewinnen und zwingend vermeiden dass die
zur AFD abwandern als Mitte September im
Thüringer Landtag ein Antrag der
oppositionellen CDU Fraktion mit Hilfe
von AFD Stimmen durchgeht äußert er
öffentlich Kritik an seinen
Parteifreunden in Erfurt ich halte das
für eine schwerwiegende Fehlentscheidung
die dort getroffen worden ist für mich
gilt unumstößlich das ist jegliche Form
des Zusammenwirkens mit der AF den nicht
geben darf gerade in Thüringen eine ja
rechtsextreme Partei ja so scheint sich
nun auch Daniel Günther immer mehr
jenseits der Grenzen Schleswig-Holsteins
Gehör verschaffen zu wollen vielleicht
um seine Fahrkarte fürs
kanzlerkandidatenkarussell zu lösen aber
wie stehen denn die Chancen der vier
Kandidaten oder der vier potentiellen
Kandidaten kann einer von ihnen Kanzler
Ende Juni hat das ZDF Politbarometer
nach allen vier potenziellen Kandidaten
der konservativen gefragt damals lagen
dem Hendrik wüst und Markus Söder bei
den Befragten mit je 22% gleich auf
Friedrich Merz hielten nur 16% für den
chancenreichsten Kandidaten und Daniel
Günther 11%. etwas anders das Bild bei
den unionsanhängern hier liegt Hendrik
wüst sogar vor Söder und März Daniel
Günther schreiben nur 10% die größten
Chancen zu laut ZDF Politbarometer vom
18 August meine nur 22% der Befragten
Friedrich Merz eignen sich als
Bundeskanzler 69% sehen das nicht so und
auch das ist ganz interessant selbst von
den unionsanhängern trauen März nur nur
39% das Kanzleramt zu im
Beliebtheitsranking der wichtigsten
Politiker Deutschlands liegt Söder Mitte
September vor März während beide bei den
Befragten Sympathiewerte im negativen
Bereich ernten genießen Sie weiterhin
den Rückhalt bei den eigenen Anhängern
weitere Unionspolitiker tauchen momentan
im Ranking der zehn wichtigsten
Politiker gar nicht auf auch Hendrik
wüst und Daniel Günther sind nicht unter
den Top 10 woran liegt das Andrea bolf
von der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen wir
fragen ja alle zwei Monate ganz offen
wer zählt denn ihrer Meinung nach zu den
wichtigsten Politikern in Deutschland
und Hendrik wüst kam da mit ein paar
Nennungen rund um die Landtagswahl in
NRW letztes Jahr allerdings jetzt bei
den letzten beiden Erhebungen die wir im
Juli und im September durchgeführt haben
da hat er durchaus etwas mehr Zuspruch
erfahren und der war da auf Platz 12
also die zehn wichtigsten werden dann ja
im nächsten Politbarometer immer
bewertet von den Befragten und er war
auf Platz 12 also schon relativ nah an
dieser Grenze also sein Wert dass er zu
den wichtigsten Politikern zählt hat
sich in den letzten Monaten erhöht auch
wenn es noch nicht gereicht hat für die
Top 10 ja und wenn ihr genauer wissen
wollt wie dieses Ranking zustande kommt
dann kann ich euch übrigens dieses Video
hier oben sehr empfehlen da haben wir
euch das schon mal erklärt Henrik wüst
scheint also auch außerhalb von
Nordrhein-Westfalen immer bekannter zu
werden aber wie steht's um Daniel
Günther ist der überregional als
Politiker präsent bei den Befragten des
der F politbarometers nein also der ist
zumindest nicht in einem Bereich äh dass
dass wir es prozentual ausweisen können
nun kann man das aber sicherlich auch
damit in Zusammenhang bringen dass NRW
eben das viel bevölkerungsreichere
Bundesland ist und dann eben auch bei
einer Bundes Befragung viel stärker
eingeht aber wenn diese diese Frage dann
noch mal ernsthafter diskutiert wird und
dann werden sicherlich alle Kandidaten
die da irgendwie eine Rolle spielen auch
äh eine größere Bekanntheit haben ja was
wir immerhin wissen ist in ihren
Bundesländern waren die beiden zuletzt
sehr erfolgreich beide haben im
vergangenen Jahr Landtagswahlen gewonnen
Hendrik wüst hat gegenüber seinem
Vorgänger Armin laschett leichte Gewinne
für die CDU in NRW einfahren können in
seinem Wahlkreis holte er bereits
zweimal hintereinander klar das
Direktmandat Daniel Günther war im
vergangenen Jahr in Schleswig-Holstein
sogar noch erfolgreicher er holte für
die CDU
33,4% und damit ganze 11,4% Punkte mehr
als 5 Jahre zuvor auch Daniel Günter
holte in seinem Wahlkreis das
Direktmandat mit einer absoluten
Mehrheit aber es ist sicherlich nicht
nur die die personelle Frage sondern
auch inhaltliche Fragen weil die Union
steht ja schon für bestimmte Bereiche in
denen sie sehr kompetent ist und ihre
kompetenzwerte in eigentlich ihr
zugeschriebenen Bereichen wie Wirtschaft
Schaffung neuer Arbeitsplätze etc hat
auch in den letzten Jahren abgenommen
und dass sie keine attraktive
Alternative zur Zeit da darstellt das
ist sicherlich eine eine Sorge die auch
viele CDU Mitglieder auch umtreibt und
die sicher auch eine entscheidende Rolle
bei dem richtigen Kandidaten spielen
wird aber dafür ist ja noch ein bisschen
Zeit denn wie wir Eingang schon
festgestellt haben wir haben gerade erst
einmal Halbzeit und ich als Fußballfan
weiß das sehr gut in der zweiten
Halbzeit kann sich ein Spiel noch drehen
ein Spiel dauert 90 Minuten eine
Legislaturperiode in der Regel 4er Jahre
und irgendwann wird dann sicher auch mal
offiziell die kfage erörtert in der
Regel werden die kanzlerkandidatinen und
Kandidaten etwas mehr als ein Jahr vor
der Bundestagswahl bekannt gegeben das
wäre dann im Sommer
2024 im September 2024 stehen allerdings
auch wichtige Landtagswahlen in den
ostdeutschen Bundesländern in Sachsen
Thüringen und Brandenburg an csuchef
Söder fordert deshalb den
unionskanzlerkandidaten erst nach diesen
Wahlen bekannt zuug geben um
gegebenenfalls auf die Wahlergebnisse
noch reagieren zu können aber nicht nur
wann sondern auch wie der jeweilige
Kandidat gekürt wird führt in der Union
zu erheblichen Diskussionen die
Ministerpräsidenten Boris rin Hendrik
wüst und berlins Regierender
Bürgermeister Kai Wegner fordern ein
Mitspracherecht bei der Entscheidung um
den Spitzenkandidaten der Union Markus
Söder und Friedrich März befürworten
einen Mitgliederentscheid wie etwa beim
Parteivorsitz einig sind sich alle
offenbar zumindest über eins dass die
Kandidaten untereinander ausfechten wer
es machen soll das soll nicht mehr
passieren beim letzten Mal hat das Duell
Söder Laschet beinahe zum Bruch der
Schwesterparteien CDU und CSU geführt
diskutiert wird jetzt schon zumindest
erheblich früher als beim letzten Mal
also schließen wir uns der Diskussion
doch einfach mal an was meint ihr denn
wird es in der Union zum wüstwums kommen
wird Friedrich Merz seinen
Führungsanspruch verteidigen oder lacht
am Ende vielleicht ein dritter aus
Bayern oder von der Küste schreibt uns
gerne in die Kommentare was ihr von
einer so frühen kfage haltet und wenn
ihr wissen wollt wie sich der aktuelle
Kanzler so schlägt dann haben wir hier
ein Video zum Teflon Scholz verlinkt und
hier findet ihr er Video zur letzten
kfage danke euch fürs zuschauen und bis
zum nächsten Mal